evening rallying to get back into school
buildings clark county school district
students peacefully protest outside more
than a dozen campuses today thanks for
joining us at six
i'm denise valdis and i'm brian loftis 8
news now reporter kristen drummond
attended a rally in the southwest valley
to learn the students concerns
drivers honk their horns showing support
for students holding signs that
send a message to ccsd leaders we need
to be
in the classrooms macy beck and some
classmates stand outside sierra vista
high school
all here rallying on their day off in
support of bringing all students back in
buildings
following nearly a year of distance
education it's hard to
adapt when everything that motivates me
in school was taken away from me
she and others highlight their
challenges during organized peaceful
protest
more than a dozen scheduled to happen
wednesday at campuses around the
district
including foothill high school as
parents we've been speaking out we've
been doing a lot of things
but these kids are old enough to say
what they want if they let us get back
into school
it'll be a lot easier to learn a big
frustration right now
only pre-kindergarten to third grade
students will return on march first for
hybrid learning
coming to campus two days for class in
person and studying remotely for three
days
students in other grade levels want that
option as well
are you worried you will continue
distance education until the end of this
academic school year
i really am and i would really like to
get back from the class
students rally not only want to get back
in buildings but also
step back on the field it's simply not
fair for all of us athletes
to you know not be able to use our
fields in practice concerns as the
school year comes to a close
in about three months kristen drummond 8
news now
and families want the board of trustees
to address those concerns so they're
planning to submit public comment for
tomorrow's meeting
and hope it makes it on the agenda later
this month brian